(keys clacking)
(dings)
(perky music)
(vomiting)
- Can I come in there?
- This, this room is my room now.
This is my den, this is my cave--
Gotta go.
- I have to get in there
before work though, babe.
- [Joey] I will build you
another bathroom, woman.
- Okay.
- When are you due?
- April.
- Nice, the off-season, huh?
- Yeah, you?
- Not 'til August.
- Ah, so you still got a
little bit of time left.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hey baby, you ready to go?
- Oh yeah, hey we should go.
Good luck, buddy.
- Damn, out pregnanted.
Two filet mingons, extra side of fries,
two wedge salads, hold the blue cheese
crumbles, extra bacon.
- Nice man, eating for two, huh?
- Oh, oh, oh, easy there little Steph.
- Babe, did you just call
her little Stephanie?
That's so cute.
- No, no, like Steph Curry, point guard
of the Golden State Warriors, duh.
- But what if it's a girl?
- Probably, Rambo.
Yeah, but he, but he touched my belly
- Okay.
- and he gave me parenting advice, so--
- Okay, stop.
Assault is a serious offense, okay?
I can't let you go scot-free.
- Touching my belly was
a threat to my dynasty.
- I'm just gonna let
you off with a warning,
I'm gonna chalk this
up to pregnancy brain.
- All right, guys, I've got the cupcakes.
GTA themed, just like you asked.
- Oh, thanks babe.
- Yeah.
Um, so you guys have any
advice for Joey and I?
- Babe, it's not a big deal.
- What are you talking about, it's huge.
- No, it can't hurt that much, if it hurt
that much people wouldn't have kids.
- Pssht.
- Whatever, dude.
- Dude, it was the most gruesome thing
I've ever experienced.
- Imagine a snake--
- [Blond Friend] I thought
everything was just gonna rip.
- Now imagine--
(eerie music)
- I wanted to die.
(gasping)
- Oh.
- Babe?
Baby, are you fine or what's going on?
(laughing)
- Oh, you make life.
You make life, oh.
- Can we go back to bed now?
(kisses)
Are we sleeping this way?
- [Dark Haired Man] Mmm-hmm.
- [Pregnant Woman] Okay.